shaky titles did not sufficiently
prepare you for the constant shakiness
you were about to see waiting also in
1995 the footage was found so that in
four years some upstart studio could
delight audiences with the real deaths
of three kids and profit handsomely from
it also their footage was found but that
means someone went into the exact same
woods as they did went into that same
creepy s house where they died and
absolutely nothing happened to the
people who found the footage after that
at the blur which set it out ups to
someone's doorstep which means it was
not so much found as it was mailed book
inventory well he's the one guy who
ended up with a decent career after this
so he who arrives last arrives hardest
or something people about to shoot a
documentary on the Blair Witch thieve a
film camera and expect not to get
murdered for that movie decides that
motion sickness is not a thing and
decides to include all the movements so
don't even think about calling us out
when the cameras last for five days
while being on constantly yeah well I'm
calling you out you see what I did there
no one will be seated during the gang
goes to get groceries scene also every
grocery store in the world would have
kicked these assholes out for using a
camera in their store myosis had that
really fancied herself the Michael Moore
of urban legend documentaries there are
an unusually high number of children
laid to rest here most of whom passed in
the 1940s yet no one in the town seems
to recall anything unusual about this
time so far you talk to one girl and she
clearly wasn't around during that time
right after this all you find her people
who want to talk about it so what the
hell are you talking about people making
a documentary on the Blair Witch have
somehow not seen this documentary young
kids started disappearing but only 1940
because which is only need to feed every
70 years due to extremely low metabolism
rates this kid is a dick to his mom's
face finally one day mr. Pryor come down
into the market and said I'm finally
finished the police finally went up on a
mountain police decided to investigate a
mountain due to a crazy old man saying
with absolutely no context
no sure The Blair Witch in addition to
being an awful murderer is also an avid
flasher so you measured four meters what
we're not in Europe the metric system it
also has our system our system so
there's two beds two guys one girl
what's the score gentlemen rampant
alcoholism but we did need to get you
grocery shopping and all that other
bullshit apart there's my son Josh once
again documentarians failed to capture
the wild alcohol-fueled banging that
occurred on the previous night roll fake
documentary credits he's guys make quite
the pair don't they
it's like the living embodiment of the
odd couple smashed together with a river
runs through it also the townspeople's
continued candidness about the Blair
Witch sup Heather cemetery monologue
pretty heart
as Heather shot the car with the water
bottle still on top of it she got this
weird feeling that she was never gonna
see this car where the water bottles
still on top of it ever again it's why
she shot it so dramatically and for so
long not dirty enough for me
documentary footage of reading a book
aloud each was bound to the other each
man's hands bound next man's feet lair
which unwittingly inspires the human
centipede ten years later people here to
document the Blair Witch somehow don't
get up to record strange noises in the
night being stoners one of them could
have possibly been an Al but the other
one was like a cackling that pretty much
makes the fact that you didn't document
it even more of us in so we're gonna go
ahead and send this a second time
documentation of Mike's patchy chest
hair boredom probably I think it's
Heather
taking your piss fetish videos first
about half of this movie is arguing and
most of that arguing is about being lost
think of the joy of being in a really
good film define good and film the Blair
Witch in addition to being a novel
murderer and a flasher is also an avid
nightly branch stomper too with campers
Michael are you saying you're not coming
down yeah white woody intelligence
dictates not to chase the sound going
down same girl who couldn't hear the
cackling the night before because she
sleeps like a rock can on the next night
suddenly hear branches snapping or
whatever the fuck that was
yes we know that Heather is making
guesses but why don't either of these
guys ever ask what the plan is having
her point to the map saying here's where
we are and here's where we're going
which could not have been a deer because
deer rarely repeat their movements two
nights in a row more than one minute of
mostly darkness and occasional blurry
footage it has everything to do with
what the piriform so loud blare which is
loud when it comes to making noises all
through the woods but she's
surreptitiously piled a bunch of rocks
just outside your tent because she's a
total silent horror up close I'm not
playing well it's the guy who's been
yelling about being done and just sick
and tired and all that bothering to
record this right now I fell asleep
they still arguing about this map
planking should have gone this movie
Maps Lies and videotape why is he
admitting this just now
why is he admitting it at all also how
did he get his hands on it and secretly
kick it into a creek anyway was it while
Heather and Josh we're making pee videos
in the woods also let's assume the blur
which didn't have anything to do with
this that Mike made this decision on his
own because it would have taken some
serious sorcery for the witch to even
know they had a map and then influenced
one of the crew to kick it into the
creek he did this because he thinks the
map is worthless despite the fact that
they found the areas they needed to find
during the shoot in my world having a
useless map is still better than not
having a map at all
Mike somehow didn't expect to get his
ass kicked for revealing this
information and holy no one actually
kicks this guy's ass I just want to say
that this is now fully six minutes of
arguing about a map in an 80 minute
movie that means at least 7.5 percent of
this is map arguing not including a
couple of other times they were lost but
thought Heather was foolish about being
able to read it primal way to gather
more energy to argue with you about the
map which arts and crafts
that's racist okay I've got everything
on video man oh Jesus Christ I didn't
even can see these man
yeah documentary buffs would have
blasted you for missing those what the
six minutes of arguing about the map
didn't bring you to that conclusion did
you guys forget the cackling Blair Witch
in addition to being an awful murderer
flasher and branch stomper is also an
avid tent puncher that footage was not
found also guy who agreed to take a film
camera out during this attack decides
not to turn the camera that way also
this movie clearly breaks the record for
the most densely populated amount of
folks in one movie also I'm sending this
movie and all the people who vomited
during it because they couldn't handle
the motion sickness I had to clean up
your vomit you couldn't wait to get to
the bathroom so Call of you and few
movie nearly one minute of darkness did
no one see anything during this entire
attack whoever did this was right there
they have two cameras and heather is so
interested in documenting this she
didn't manage to get anything at all
Josh's stuff was obviously thrown around
because he accidentally kicked those
rocks earlier but why didn't the Blair
Witch just kill him that'll teach you to
with rocks dude this is a bizarre threat
since you're in the fucking woods
already how about kicking her in the
creek since she's useless to love to
hell but no one documented that blue
jelly at any point during a movie where
people are documenting arguments over
maps
the star-spangled banner' blare which
would really really like these assholes
to leave the woods but decides to trick
their sense of direction into going back
to the exact same places Josh is ultra
pissed at Heather for getting them lost
but apparently no one has any anger left
for Mike who kicked the fucking map into
the river okay here's your motivation
you're lost you're angry in the wood man
Josh's meson scent is all done it's
actually amazing Heather doesn't thrash
Josh right now and considering the weak
sauce he put up against Mike a minute
ago she would win pretty easily
having seen the dailies for this
documentary you never really had that
either of course not we're shooting a
documentary here we didn't bring the
tools for scripts wait the one guy here
who is definitely beyond a shadow of a
doubt sick and tired of the camera is
the one shooting this Lots jeez what a
dick
Josh what's your favorite thing to do on
a Sunday irony but wrong filming stuff
is all you had left remember nearly one
minute of darkness Josh Oh twig gift
also I don't know how the hell these
people get to sleep at night with all
this stuff going on jump cut affection I
guess this is supposed to be hair teeth
and blood but honestly I'll never really
know it's amazing the movie even shows
us this also which gives the gift of
Josh's hair teeth and blood but decides
to keep his hatred of Heather to herself
also in addition to being an awful
murderer flasher branch stomper and tent
puncher well actually she's a pretty
goddamn awful murderer
damn what happened Heather neither shows
the bloody hair teeth to Mike nor tells
him about it it's no worse than eating a
clapperboard nostril exam but the dad's
they owe me an apology it's not because
of me that we're here how hungry cold
and hunted hunted it implies that she
hasn't found you yet with is the phrase
you're looking for
we'll have to go in because I can't
resist the smell of gingerbread they
actually took two cameras with them in
this search for Josh didn't they
I guess it makes sense if they have
lights on them and everything but damn
did they not bring any flashlights black
handprints remind us that kids were
killed by the Blair Witch long ago and
had their hands dipped in black ink
before dying for some reason okay so one
of the townspeople told us about the
standing in the corner thing with the
dead kids earlier and then he would kill
the other one
they was done with that he grabbed the
one out of the corner and kill that one
too but how pointless is that you in the
corner I'm gonna kill your friend then
I'll kill you
besides how did she make Mike stand here
Mike is a grown-ass man oh man it was a
real damn I just started a fund to help
their families and everything
you
I'm not playing head games I gave you
back the map Heather I gave you back the
map seems like you guys are having just
a little bit too much fun for my day you
know what you need Heather you know what
you really need you need a good stiff
dick
hmm Greg Greg what are you doing ice
might be from the old lady's liquor
cabinet yeah whoa do you smoke too while
wandering the woods fighting about maps
and occasionally looking for the Blair
Witch these three kids could clearly
have benefitted from some healthy tasty
energizing snacks unfortunately for them
naturebox didn't exist when they made
this documentary so they died thankfully
for you naturebox does exist today
future
ah geez just go to naturebox commons and
you can be chowing down on vittles
delivered straight to your door right
now naturebox wants to give you a free
sampler box of some of their most
popular snacks and they're all freakin
delicious with thousands of varieties of
sweet and salty snacks you are sure to
find enough to fuel your own filmmaking
or getting lost in the woods dreams
remember that's naturebox.com/tyler box
shipped to your door or you know you can
just continue shouting different Josh's
name in the hopes that he isn't dead and
might bring you something to eat
but to be safe go naturebox